all right huell packard leaves
california yeah
for texas and headquarters jump governor
abbott is on a state
recruiting spree i love that yeah
huel packard has made the decision to
relocate its headquarters to san jose
calif from san jose california to
houston texas
they're the largest u.s employment hub
houston is an attractive market to
recruit and retain
future diverse talent and it's where the
company is currently constructing a
state-of-the-art new campus
the bay area will continue to be a
strategic cup for hpe
hewlett packard innovation and the
company will con consolidate
a number of sites in the bay area and
it's san jose campus
no layoffs are associated with this move
we are excited that hewlett-packard
enterprise has chosen to call texas home
and i thank them for expanding their
investment
in a lone star stay by relocating their
headquarters to houston region abbott
wrote in a statement hewlett-packard
enterprise joins more than
50 fortune 500 companies
headquartered in the lone star state
including 22
in houston area alone i got you i'm
going to set you up tom
here we go i'm going to let you slam
dunk this bad boy so what is hewlett
packard famous for they're famous for
literally being the company that started
silicon valley like
it started there was a guy hewlett and
there's a guy packard
and they started sort of in the bezos
approach they started their company in a
one-car garage
in uh silicon valley palo alto there you
go
there's literally a historical landmark
with a plaque
that says the birthplace of silicon
valley at
this location this one car garage in
palo alto
so me being a florida boy i've never
lived in california i've spent some
some summer times there you know
obviously we're in texas now so i'm
going to throw this back to you tom
i'm going to throw this back to you pat
being you know living in california now
born you know not born but raised in
california you know when you came to the
states
what do you hear what do you feel like
when you hear all these
companies like because elon musk has
talked about it there's been multitude
of
silicon valley s-type companies that are
leaving the state you obviously left the
state
you know you're thinking about it wink
wink what do you think about when you
hear all these companies that are
basically saying all right dude enough's
enough
we're getting out of california we saw
ben shapiro leave california he's moving
to nashville
slash boca raton joe rogan did it elon
musk is talking about it
pbd did it send you up time what the
hell is going on in california
yeah it's a revolution i mean it's just
the beginning if a company like
hewlett-packard can do it they're set in
the playbook now for
tesla for some of these other big
companies that are going to do it is
becoming impossible to stay in
california if you're a big business like
this think about the decision involved
in this
the amount of employees probably 10 000
employees that you're going to relocate
what about all the data that you got to
move what about building a new corporate
headquarters in houston i mean this is
no quick decision i mean there must have
been and then
you probably go back to newsome and you
say hey we're thinking of doing this
is there anything you can do to inspire
us or to incentivize us to stay
he clearly doesn't i think a guy like
elon musk are going why hasn't he moved
yet i think he's just waiting
he will move there is no way you can
stay in california
if you're a big business like that now
the googles of the world the apples of
the world they're so big to their own
country basically
that it doesn't really matter and so
much of their business is done outside
of
uh silicon valley and whatnot but i
think
this is only going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and if hp can do it
anybody can do it uh we had somebody
just commented right now cryptochart
says hp isn't even that relevant these
days
only thing is printers right is what
he's saying about hp but
by the way hp is a pretty big company if
you pull up hp pull up heel pack or
wikipedia
to see how many employees these guys got
and and what kind of numbers they're
putting up
uh uh i think it's like 60 000 worldwide
it's it's go
go up go up there's still a fortune 500
company go up go up go up right there
click on that let's see where they're at
employee wise uh
keep going up keep going up it's going
to show on the top on the right you
don't need to do that guy
just close that and go up right there to
the right
okay uh you know what some of those you
know opponent management is worldwide
typically they put the employees right
there
interesting that they don't have it over
here so what what is their number of how
big they are
i think it's about sixty thousand can
you see how many total employees at
hewlett
how many employees does your packer have
yeah does hugh
packer have there you go 55 000
employees i'm almost at it
top 10 competitors averaged 90 000. okay
they got their ninth among
top top ten competitors where are you
going with this pack 55 000 employees is
what they have so
this is not a small company to say
they're doing that this is not a
schlep that's just saying hey we're
going to move our stuff to texas great
word
and the fact that what he said he says a
move like this
is not like an overnight decision that
you make okay i'm going to make a crazy
prediction here i'll make a crazy
prediction here
i think if there's ever been a time
where someone on the center right can go
win
the office in california and be a
governor right now is the time to do it
oh yeah
newsome's making it easy i think if
there's ever been a time for somebody in
california to go and become a governor
center right if you know somebody or
you you know have someone that you think
would
have the likes to go do it you may want
to inspire them i had a couple
conversations with a couple
influential guys in california i said
how come you're not running why are you
not running behind closers i don't want
to
you know share their vision of what they
want to do i said why don't you run in
and we had an
extensive comment says you know i'm
actually thinking about it and i'm
trying to inspire a handful of people
who wouldn't make good governors to go
run you're
these guys here i think california in
the next
i would not be surprised in the next 4 8
12 years california is going to have a
solid center
right governor who is going to be fine
with lgbtq
i'm not talking ted cruz type of a
governor yeah i'm talking about a
arnold schwarzenegger type no he wasn't
able to get anything done because behind
but he was the center right
he said they didn't let me get nothing
done they didn't let him get
nothing done he was like arrested for
eight years
meaning by folks on the other side his
hands today so what type of person do
you have in mind i think somebody like a
rock could do it if he wanted to go on
that side i think somebody that is a
cent independent but you have to choose
a side i think someone today could win
the state of california because
newsom is almost at a point where he
really doesn't give a [ __ ] about
the small business owners in the state
of california play that video kai sent
to you
the one with the interview where all of
a sudden the guy in the background the
small business owner flips
and this is in the middle of a
commentary uh uh
uh yeah i i it's a twitter link i sent
you
uh see if you can find it by the way in
the meantime i am backing a candidate
in california right he's a republican
he's a moderate his name is ricky
aguilar
he's a big-time uh capitalist
i like what he has to say he's a
reasonable guy
i don't think he can get somebody out of
the business community though because
there's a lot of qualified people i
think in business that could do it the
number one guy that i think would be a
great governor is bob eisner
um leaving disney the timing's perfect
he's pissed at newsome but i just
don't think because of his industry that
he could be center right i don't know
or the the president disney eiger
or or michael eisenhower no not
eisenhower my bad sorry bob iger
is left though yeah i know that's my
point yeah yeah he would be i look he's
mad
he doesn't want to be he doesn't want to
be governor he wants to be a president
okay but a guy like him but i don't
think you can come out of the business
community just because you can't come
out of the entertainment world i don't
think rock could do it because there's
no way he could ever align himself
anything other than left he can't yeah i
agree with him not being able to do that
although i do think he's a center right
guy
um i i just think there's a time for it
because you know
here's here's how life works and what
i've noticed over the years
you and i may have 50 different things
that we're not in common with we can
disagree on 50 different things
there's one thing we all agree on which
is what i got to make money to support
my family
period and if a guy keeps costing me
jobs
and i used to work for hewlett-packard
it's moving to houston i don't want to
go to houston
or all these companies that are leaving
and i'm a democrat
and i'm losing my job and i have to come
again to five of my wife my wife gets a
divorce she leaves me because we can't
take care of the kids my kids have to
leave the school that we're going
i'm sorry i'm no longer thinking about
politics i'm thinking about my pocket
the more you hurt my pocket i'm
eventually going to vote with my pocket
and what the democrats lose with this is
why the democrats can't become president
stay president
for 20 years straight because every
eight years when somebody's affected in
the pocket they say dude
i'm sorry you know what why don't we try
a little bit of the right
why don't we try a little bit of the
right why don't we try a little bit
right to get the economy you know
well let's try a little bit about to get
the taxes to be lower let me make and
save some money
i think california folks if they get hit
in the pocket i think they're gonna
watch what happens right here with a
small business owner look at the
emotional reaction he has
so basic interview this channel is doing
wwmt
and watch what happens in the middle of
it it's pretty crazy is it in l.a where
is it just watch
why the judge said no
marius is everything okay okay my
government leaders have abandoned me
it's one minute are you are you the
owners of
four trillion dollars of stimulus money
and gave it to who
special interest groups and campaign
donors i'm dave morris i own the place
so what's going on what's going on you
know what's going on tell me you tell me
hey we got a government that has taken
the stimulus money
they gave it to special campaign donors
they gave it to special interests
abandoned me and they had put me in a
position where
i have to fight back okay so do you feel
that this is the right thing to do
absolutely i feel everybody needs to
stand up hey listen
there was enough money to give every
family every family in this country
twenty thousand dollars to go home for
two months
they chose to give it to special
interests right about the campaign
donors
the kennedy space center and they
abandoned us
you could have given me money i'd gladly
walk away for 60 days and let this virus
settle down
i'm not going to do it alone okay are
you going to continue to violate the
state's orders and stay open
this isn't an order this is a conspiracy
this is a tyranny
what do you want to tell other
restaurant owners who wake up stand up
this is america be free
can you tell how pissed you're coming
supporting me do you blame them let them
keep going
is it over is that yeah
what state is he in what state is the
important where's portage
p-o-r-t-a-g-e portage
uh portage learning portage
yeah that's right yeah good form for
doing this yeah i like the way the
reporter had to did it
asking questions you know what it's
turning um you know they were protesting
outside the
the non-doctor that is the head of the
health
community in in los angeles that makes
all the covet decisions yesterday
garcetti said did you hear his quote he
says shut everything down that was his
quote yesterday
shut everything down um now
the other thing in la is the judge said
that they're going to give the county
one week to come back and prove
that outdoor dining is a is there's data
that shows that it spreads coronavirus
or else i think the restaurants are
going to
be able to open up again outdoors but
people are fighting and they're
really really to me that is such
[ __ ] shutting down yeah outdoor
dining
restaurant we had to eat at in in la i
mean
look i i get indoor dining i get
shutting down bars i guess
shutting down fifty percent capacities
he's outdoor dining
he's putting one authority to destroy
you know look look for someone to come
out of orange county because orange
county's pretty big
they have a history of being very you
know right leaning very and they are
ticked off what
his decision to not allow disneyland to
open reverberates because it's not
berry farm it's hotels it's all those
restaurants that are around there
it's the there's hundreds of businesses
that have gone under because of that
decision
yeah i mean you know you know you ever
gone to a funeral
and when you go to the funeral you're at
a funeral where the person wasn't
directly
related to you and you didn't have that
strong of a relationship with the person
who died
but they were to somebody you ever been
to you're like you know what
i'm not emotionally connected to this
person but i'm going to pay my respects
i'm going to go to the funeral and then
you see somebody come up
and they just break down telling a story
about their relationship with this
person how they lost them
and you can't help but what sit there
and say dude i feel this guy
empathy i went to a funeral in miami
and this was somebody that i love this
is a guy that died who
i i love dearly family okay and i knew
what he died from
okay i knew what he died from because he
was a hardcore partier
this guy cooked food for me every sunday
at my house i'd come i'd come home from
a
workout and he's in my house cooking
with my wife i mean he was like a
freaking
incredible guy and he died from cocaine
overdose
okay so i go to miami too's funeral and
i see his stepfather
get up doesn't speak very good english
and he got up
wow and he got up and he said i told him
i told him i've been telling him for
years i
told him you have to i knew this day was
i had nightmares about this day i knew
this day was coming i was scared of this
day
and this man is in his 70s and he's just
it's just coming down there is he's not
speaking good
he's not a good speaker he's just
telling you bro i am in pain i was
afraid of this day he lost his son 33
years old when this guy died 32 years
old this guy died right
i'm saying i freaking i cannot stand
this
i watch a guy like this this is not a
motivational speaker a republican to
them he's just telling you dude
i'm trying to run a damn business just a
business owner get the hell out of my
way let me pay these p
employees i'm trying to stay in business
what are you doing
and you watch his pain and it's not just
saying that's just one guy in michigan
you got restaurants in california taking
his you got restaurants in new york
taking it
you got all these people playing all
these political games what they're not
realizing is
these people have put their entire life
savings into this business
it's painful seeing that happen and it's
almost watching him it's like watching a
funeral of a small business
yeah and they've been watching the
restaurants totally dying
i can't stand that man it's really bad
and if you love america to see what's
happening with this kind of culture
and environment is allowing something
like this to happen
shout out to donald ho he gave
10 bucks good mother said just said
thank you yeah
good mother said that guy is smarter
than these university grads the guy with
the school
called connection said big pictures the
employees of these companies are
bringing their leftist ideology to texas
and will vote the same way they did in
california red state selling out with
low tax
incentives will bite back i agree
there's a point to that what's happening
in arizona i agree with that
michael gave ten bucks and said how has
rafi's place been handling california
restrictions obviously they're being hit
with it because
when we went at rafi's place to eat we
we sat outside now they can't even do
that
number one restaurant number five
unrelated underpoint you have considered
a new window of scott adams on the main
street main channel we'll consider that
if baba brando brando commando said if
baba goran for office the far left would
jump down his throat
for how he treated disney employees
wages they did the same thing
to bloomberg and trump but trump could
handle this criticism
i think bob iger could also handle the
criticism and thank you also marilyn for
your love look
you know you you sit here and you see
these stories
of a huge packer moving to texas and you
ask yourself what the guy said they're
going to bring their leftist policies
but he also sit there and say how much
longer are
are is the massive exodus going to take
place
not exodus there's a difference between
an exodus and a mass exodus
a mass exodus is what they're gone okay
they're permanently gone they're being
mistreated
they're not treating people respectfully
there's gonna be issues that are gonna
be taking place
at what point do you see 50 companies
leaving at what point do you see
bigger names leaving at what point do
you see that with california is that
going to happen over the next video
silicon valley within uh palo alto there
is
a framework and giving reasons to stay
legislation incentives specifically in
that area because i was wondering why
the hell aren't these companies
why aren't more moving but there is
infrastructure you know a a brain trust
a bubble
in silicon valley for reasons to stay
that's why these companies do stay there
but other places in california i totally
understand san francisco
jesus
you